[Music]
no
raja no
no
[Music]
what do you want me to do with that i
don't want that
in the palace
[Music]
nobody's gonna know
nobody's going to know they're going to
know
how would they know
who would afford to be shining coming
away from the doubt days on the house
where my name just dropped from a place
where the angels are blazing no one's
able to count me i'm not about pressure
impose that they're only able to pull
pay pre-demeanor and that means a solo
[Music]
[Applause]
street
[Music]
things in my ice castle that just makes
sense
i hollowed out the sides of this
staircase and put led lights in so no
one misses them
this is my bedroom the bed frame is ice
but the bed is not
because i am a human being not a monster
this is my sculpture garden
i come out here to reflect on life and
decide whether or not to let things go
this is where i store my extra ice
thanks to my brother-in-law i have a
good hook up
and i made this entire bookshelf out of
ice including the books
maybe this one doesn't make much sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
waking up in the morning thinking about
so many things
i just wish things would get better i'm
trying to get rid of them
but nothing seems to stay the same
[Music]
i'm gonna show y'all how to make my
daddy's famous gumbo
first we're gonna take our chopped up
andouille and put it in our large hot
pan
so that's what that's for
today's thrifting haul oh it was such a
good day
i mean is this not the most beautiful
thing you've ever seen what do we call
this one
a snagglethorpe so i have legs now
and um i obviously wanted to try the
viral tic-tac-legging so
okay ooh i like the color i don't know
who needs to hear this
but do not sign contracts without
reading all of the fine print first
[Music]
i think i met her in the
[Music]
no lobby musical like who is you so
viewable she kept it one
two zeros like yes finally someone hit
refresh
you guys i just finished the most
wonderful book about a prince and an
ogre and a magic beanstalk and
well my favorite part you'll see when
you get to chapter three
so i just moved to this new castle and
the guy who owns it is like never go
into this one wing of the house which
that's weird right so i think i need to
figure out what's in that wing
like for part two
you